o que você vai ser quando crescer
quem nunca escutou essa pergunta e quem
nunca fez essa pergunta uma criança
todos nós escutamos tem certeza disso
eu escutei eu era uma dessas crianças
nessa foto ao lado da professora e eu já
tinha resposta
eu queria ser a astrônoma
eu queria ser cientista eu era daquelas
crianças que queria saber tudo que fazia
perguntas sobre tudo o que queria saber
o porquê onde como e que não satisfaziam
com respostas não eram boas e eu adorava
universo eu queria saber se o universo
online a 270 nasa estava mandando sondas
espaciais pelo sistema solar e eu queria
saber como é que essas e mais chegavam
aqui e ninguém sabe responder então eu
decidi que eu ia virar a cientista
mas aí eu escutava a como é que você vai
fazer isso você é maluca menina você vai
morrer de fome é um desinformado
trabalho é coisa de menina não não faça
isso é bom
já se passaram 20 anos desde que eu
ganhei o meu doutorado com muito esforço
na usp
eu não morri defourny eu trabalho na
nasa
mas foram anos muito duros foram anos de
muita dedicação ser cientista não é
fácil mas foram anos maravilhosos então
eu escolhi pra vocês
uma das descobertas que eu tenho na
minha bagagem está a contar pra vocês
ela aconteceu aqui neste observatório no
chile o chile tem as melhores condições
para observações astronômicas as
montanhas são altas cercas as noites são
escuras e maravilhosas e tem grandes
telescópios no chile
eu utilizei esse
durante o meu doutorado
pois é eu estava observando era uma
noite fria
era uma noite maravilhosa
eu estava sozinha e ouvir algo estranho
na telinha do telescópio e se há algo
estranho
ali marcado na imagem era uma estrela
intrusa que não deveria estar ali porque
eu tinha um mapa do céu eu contei as
estrelas não era tratar dele mas estava
esse telescópio que eu estava utilizando
ele mostra a composição química do
objeto que está observando então podia
ter deixado pra lá eu podia ter
simplesmente observado o meu objeto que
era aquela galaxy ali mas não aquela
menina curiosa lá que fazer pergunta
porque como onde novamente ela fez a
pergunta certa na hora certa embutem o
telescópio de direção e passa em cima
daquela estrela estranha
hoje a gente sabe que aquela estrela
estranha é uma estrela que explodiu uma
supernova uma estrela que explodiu há 56
milhões de anos
legal né mas o mais legal disso nem a
minha descoberta mais legal disso é
saber que essas estrelas quando os podem
elas têm muita importância na nossas
origens na nossa vida
o ferro que está no nosso sangue o
cálcio está nos nossos ossos o oxigênio
que a gente respira tudo isso é feito
dentro das estrelas estrelas quando elas
produzem energia quando elas produzem
luz anos produzem também elementos
químicos e não há outra forma na
natureza de produzir elemento químico só
dentro das estrelas
então vamos fazer aqui um exercício
vamos respirar fundo fechou os olhos e
respire fundo
de novo a sentir o cheirinho de estrela
tudo isso aí gente o oxigênio é feito
dentro das estrelas lembra sempre diz
e quando eu era aquela menina eu queria
saber a isso eu queria era ter esse
conhecimento para passar para todo mundo
eu queria que o universo fosse meu
laboratório ele é eu conheço universo
a palma da minha mão então se algum dia
vocês encontrarem uma menina uma criança
que vai dizer pra vocês que ela quer ser
cientista que ela tem aquele brilho nos
olhos lembre aquele brilho nos olhos foi
feito dentro das estrelas é o brilho das
estrelas e que sim
não existe barreira pra nada com muito
esforço seguindo o seu talento e que até
é possível descobrir uma estrela muito
obrigada